[Music]
hey everyone
welcome hey hi hi
we have wrapped up bentino massaro's
costa rica shift into permanent
alignment
retreat this is our last
podcast that we are doing on site
and we have hillary hoffman and gina
sutton joining us on the show
hey hi
this is good yeah what a good
form of completion you know to
just dive into what we've been through
and i think it's been a week
so i'm i'm really grateful to have
connected with all of you
me too it's wild yeah
yeah yeah
just say the least yeah there's
yeah it was it was beautiful seeing how
the container
that was formed by bentino and the team
over so many years of preparation
ended up facilitating these
people to identify their calling
get through their limiting beliefs
make declarations about
just archiving things that no longer
serve them and elevating and amplifying
the most divine
aligned purified service to other
igniting global awakening
things that rocket them forward yeah
yeah absolutely it was cool to see
the change in people
you could tell energetically at the
beginning when you tell in yourself
you're just in a totally different place
you feel completely different
and then now here we are yes and we're
yeah yeah it's like on cloud now i mean
i feel like i look completely different
than i did when i walked in i felt like
a zombie a week ago
and then here i feel now just so light
radiant and just like
completely shifted on like not only an
energetic but yeah vibrational level
it is wild so yeah it's been
incredible and just like witnessed the
yeah the container that it was
so perfectly divinely placed and
everything was
like the shifts that they did um even
behind the scenes and like
how they would kind of provoke us like
you know make us really like dive into
our own
i went through some serious phases of
like self-judgment and then i had to
detach from that
and that alone is so powerful because i
realized that like i am not that and i
can detach from that
yeah and i'm like that's just like
already been a thing
and i'm just like whoa so there's just
been so much shift in my own perception
and yeah limiting beliefs for sure
yeah absolutely yeah i think that's yeah
one of the main
shifts is just putting those limiting
beliefs down and they just almost seem
like
not they just don't seem true anymore
and you just can't even believe them
anymore
and then your experience backs it up and
then you get really
yeah you're just like really convicted
in that yeah
and it's really cool yeah i love i love
what you guys are saying that
the behavior change follows
these declarations it's in a sense one
has to have enough
courage yeah to identify
these impurities these distortions and
then to
archive those to
to heal and to integrate to transcend
and include as is said by so many of the
greats and so i love that a lot i think
from a macro level another way to view
it is that in a sense
even though we already came away from
like the separate entity contraction
right even though we already were like
quite far away from that
yeah yeah eve even though we were
already like quite far away into this
more relaxed
more expanded state it this retreat even
further expanded and even further
relaxed and even further
identified the most nuanced distortions
most nuanced layers of the cheeky [ __ ]
that is the ego
yeah it was cool to
feel that coming up during the retreat
and you could feel the most there's some
sort of distortion that felt the most
tense and
you probably we all had different ones
but it would come up in the retreat
during the retreat and you're starting
to
understand how to work with that and
it's really cool to be able to
feel it like leave you yep and or you
could just
be like nope like out of sheer will
yeah they'll live and then yeah and then
the conviction follows
right after you keep doing that which is
pretty cool to see
the personal choice right like knowing
that we always have that choice
kind of like we're discussing last night
there's a buffet
how did you word that yeah yeah yeah we
go from this
buffet of options in this realm of
suffering
in the escape room the 3d matrix
we all have different escape rooms that
we've programmed for ourselves
to get out of but then there's also the
buffet in terms of
that was the root one and then there's
the branch fruit one and then that's
sort of
where we end up blossoming which is why
our callings are
all very somewhat similar in igniting
the global awakening but
that's the buffet is why some people
choose the word maybe
truth and some people choose inspiration
and do
people choose different words in that so
yeah there's like these two funny
buffets
yes yeah yeah i like this buffet better
many more options you know many more
personal choices available that i had
no clue existed that i didn't know i
could leave my
anxiety my depression and just reach an
elevated state where that all is just
like a choice to be made
yeah instead of just like a state that
i'm in i can
be the observer and like zoom out of it
instead of just like not being able to
see the forest through the trees anymore
like
i'm not even in the forest anymore i'm
like in like a little
uh what are they called just like a gosh
like a rocket ship a rocket ship or like
yeah a plane above it looking down
yeah it's amazing you've become even
more
macro level view than you were even
before that's
yeah that's huge because when you're in
your problems
you you can only think on that level of
like how do i solve this like you're
very external
and you don't have any perspective and
then yeah as you go higher up in these
these other states of consciousness you
get all the perspective
it all starts making sense and
feels much lighter yeah more like
malleable and
fun and yeah much better a drone
you can just see so much right above it
and it's like you're flying over the old
the old you in a way right like this you
that is still
like down there but it's just like much
in a lower version of
reality or whatever this reality is this
matrix
and you actually have the choice to see
it for what it is instead of just being
lost
and that alone is such a shift because
no like you can really align to your
vibration now and just know that like
this
this feeling i can carry with me and
then when i'm like
kind of like rubber banded out away from
this feeling i can
choose to come back and i don't have to
stay out of that alignment like i know
that there's a better feeling right
yeah you know better you do better you
feel better because you just know better
and you can't i know
that's the good yeah once you see
through
maya you can't unsee it and we were
talking about this a bit last night is
that
the obsession with infinity and with
transients
and physicalism and the external
is the simple shift needs to just go
from the outside
to the to the inside like it's taught in
the parable of the prodigal son and all
these mystic traditions
and when you do that and you recognize
that consciousness or awareness
and infinity then you recognize that
this is just one of our creations and
that we are the permanent we
are the source we are the infinitude
that then
this is just one song of our eternal
symphony
and so it's just that you know that
simple shift and then just to play with
the analogies to intertwine them
i love the steak and rubber band analogy
and the way that it plays with the
escape room analogy is really
really interesting it's like we
conditioned this contracted separate
entity escape room
and then the rubber bands pulled out so
the stake is the highest
aligned guidance with our
calling with full pure service to others
god's love light and then the rubber
band when it stretches out is like when
you fall back into the person psychology
you go with contraction
and then the emotional guidance system
comes and it's like yo
when your rubber bands out here and you
think that oh i'm going to extract
peace and happiness from other people or
from the world
yeah that then the emotional guidance
system kicks in
and you're told that you're you're so
you're signaled hey
like catch this bring your rubber band
back to the stake and keep aligning with
the highest
and that has to do with the escape room
as well because in a sense these are
like the little like
walls you know in the escape room in a
sense
that you're dissolving these the
emotional guidance systems helping you
dissolve the escape room walls bring the
rubber band
back yes yeah that's huge
and it's it's so interesting that we
live in a
culture that doesn't value emotions or
tries to cut you off from them
and like express yeah don't think about
them
they're kind of like just bs you know
like oh you're feeling like [ __ ] it's
okay like just
completely disregard it like it doesn't
mean anything almost
uh and it's really cool to be able to
connect back
to your emotions your emotional guidance
system because it
it really is such a it's such
guidance like if you just listen to that
you can really start to tell when you're
getting out of alignment because it just
feels like [ __ ]
and then more you feel like [ __ ] the
more out of alignment you are and then
you can shift back and then you start to
feel
just this sense of ease and you can
start feeling that and it gets more
subtle as you practice like i'm getting
a little bit out
and then you keep coming back so it's
very experiential it's very like
visceral
you feel it vibrationally as your legs
yeah adjusting yeah definitely yeah like
powerful like very tangible feeling
eventually but
i feel like i used to not even be able
to realize when i was in that state
whereas now i can like
know and i've always felt that you have
to really feel your emotions to heal
them but like
you don't like and you have to right
like that's a part of it it's part of
the emotional guidance you have to
really feel them
but you also have the knowledge wisdom
light within to know that like
when you actually feel them that's how
you release them many people get stuck
in this hamster wheel me
being one of them in the past where i
felt like i had to
like just numb it out or run away from
it distract myself ostracize and be like
no i'm just going to run from my
like and numb it and then when when you
do that you literally just run hamster
wheels back to it so when you choose and
then it manifests in like
dis ease in your body disease and like
all kinds of things when you actually
let that stress
and that emotion and like depression
build up in you instead of just
feeling it then you can heal it because
then you literally alchemize it
from pain to healing and then release it
into
what just knowing it's not yours it's
not yours
in into creatorship
yeah yeah the al chemistry
happens we condition ourselves into the
escape room into the contracted separate
entity we
alchemically undergo the processes of
leveraging that emotional guidance
system
bringing the rubber band back to the
stake yeah and then as we align more and
more
with god's love light our own infinitude
our own
creatorship that
that becomes the highest signal
metaphysically
of who we are why we're here what we're
doing that kind of stuff
yeah yeah it's yeah it's so
it's what a realization yeah it's so
nice to just be grounded in that
and really keep focusing inward like
you're saying like that's the
direction just like keep going back
because really
like bentino says this like don't take
your cue from your circumstances and i
love that
because a lot of the time we're looking
around thinking
oh [ __ ] like i need to change something
out there
or or even you just take it personally
or you're disappointed or whatever
but really it's like just keep shifting
back
yeah that's it the abiding dividing
this tripod has been playing with the
word abiding
it's great a bite is a perfect word
because when you when you begin tasting
like
you you taste because you can't not
abide which is why
it's perfect already and always already
free
but it's also perfecting in the sense
that
when you do recognize that you are the
eternal
sky of awareness that the thought clouds
and whatnot
appear and disappear in you become more
aware of the need to abide
as awareness to no longer have the
thought cloud sort of take your monkey
mind
yeah you're just like resting in your
more natural state
yeah yeah and then abiding even further
as the creator of even awareness itself
experiencing the realities and so then
you need to abide as that yeah
so to constantly in a sense be making
the necessary
juxtapositions between infinity and
infinity and abiding as
infinity relentlessly you know over and
over again you know necessary
and continuous brought it up as well is
that
perpetual nettie nettie equals freedom
perpetually creating a juxtaposition
over and over again i am not infinity i
am not infinity i'm awareness i'm not
infinity i'm not affinity i'm not even
awareness i'm the creator
yeah yeah yeah what does that look like
for you
like what we just described yeah yeah
like this perpetual
yeah kind of like um like behavior wise
because for me i would say i would like
to do more
like longer meditations like that and i
feel i can now because it just actually
feels good and i'm
able to drop in but it to me it looks
like throughout the day
i'm constantly checking in like that
that's right
yeah yeah if i feel i'm like really
outside in my circumstances like coming
back to that awareness
and just abiding yeah and keep going
i understand that yeah i mean i think um
increment
or yeah like just briefly taking moments
to breathe and check in with your breath
throughout the day is really important
and just when you're in either the car
or walking like
taking one foot in front of the other
just really realizing your surroundings
and your senses
for me personally i do enjoy having
meditation practice
like in the morning and then at night
before bed it just really
allows me to witness and observe my my
thoughts my emotions instead of being in
the middle of them and i think it really
takes me from like a reactive state to a
responsive state
to where i'm not just like feeling that
i am my senses
right i'm able to actually like step
back when i'm either in a
moment of just having like oh whether
it's like someone cutting me off in
traffic or someone like
that i'm interacting with feeling very
misaligned with who i am knowing that
that's all it's meant to be it's meant
to be like a challenge for me and
i think having my practice really just
grounds me in knowing that i can respond
versus react and takes me out of just
like my mind
but it is really important to do i also
have moments where i'm just like
inhale exhale like taking that deep
breath and just grounding into the
present moment
is so important noticing like the crisp
on the leaves or just like all of the
beautiful sensational things that we
often don't even recognize because we're
so in here you know
yeah yeah i love what richard said like
one of the facilitators here teachers he
said
um like what's your mind your mind's
like a prediction
machine like it keeps wanting to get
some kind of
grasp on the future what's going to
happen tomorrow
and you'll start to notice that when
you're really up here and you're doing
that
that you're you're quite taken out of
that state of just pure awareness and
abiding yeah and it and it really um
is what do i need what do i need what
exactly is
what do i lack right now it's just a
limiting yeah it's like lack belief
it's a lack belief and uh yeah i think
what served us for an evolutionary
period of time yeah
for a million or so or something years
yeah you realize you don't really
you don't need it though it's like
pretty crazy you think that oh i have to
plan out everything in my life or i need
to think about
yeah just worry about all these
different things but when you start
releasing that and you live very
presently
and faith devotion surrender
to god's love light that's already
omnipresent and already
flowering effortlessly towards the sun
yeah and you just
feel this perfection that's everything's
already working out
the all is well feeling yeah yeah the
hall is well as well
and then you just rest in that and then
everything
just flows so let's also visualize this
it's really exciting to do so those were
great examples of
your practices with abiding and
surrendering
yeah and the visualization that can
sometimes
help is you know rather than seeing
first probably and foremost is
everywhere you look and everywhere
that you are recognize rather than
there being separation between you and
other people and you
and the world see it as your own
creation of
absolute love and light and then
see rather than seeing like the
instead of seeing the form and the
identity
and all these layers of costume which
are fantastic
the costumes are fantastic but they're
also
very separative
yeah and individuated which is which is
also unique in its in its sense
but what you can do instead is you can
begin sort of
seeing the awareness the pure bear
empty awareness that is shared as it as
the
fundamental i am that is present
and timeless here and then to sort of
repeatedly do that over and over again
to where even the form and the identity
sort of melt into just this like
love light interacting with itself
and it's in its little evolutionary
ascent that it's going through right now
remember your visualization like snap
everyone is light everyone has white
lights walking around
okay snap back they're back in form it's
so good
that is just like a beautiful
demonstration and visualization to just
really like drop in and recognize we are
not these spacesuits but we are just
you know they're quite deceiving like
you said you know and they can get
really distracting
and cause for a lot of like diving in
and knowing our soul and making that
more pure and beautiful
and dissolving into the absolute that we
are all one is so much more exciting
so much more exciting yeah going in with
again work yeah
it's not external and i think that's
really important but a lot of us
are so in that external world right like
we feel like we are our senses which i
mean like you said it was good for a
brief time
survival mode it helped us survive um
but now we're just evolving past that
like separation
and it's so exciting like yeah i'm so
excited about it
uh it feels just like a remembrance like
a lot of what bentino talks about it's
just like it feels like i'm remembering
things that i
i've known for centuries and whether
i've only been in this body 28 years
it's like i know that like i've had
these connections with
like these souls before and just like
knowing this
beautiful information and i feel like
we've
evolved as humans but we've also kind of
like devolved in a way of our
consciousness but it's like programmed
it's the matrix it's meant for that
and we're we're stepping out we're
taking the gold pill
that's what lisa said the gold pill i
like that i like that instead of that
the white pills
those are good ones to play with because
the red and blue have been bastardized
by society
yeah yeah but it's cool that they have
gold or white
are like these ascensionary and gold's
good i like that yeah
it's good that's a good one it's the
pill
ultimately of the true nature and
the true nature requires above all
inward
period and that in itself is something
that
people again the escape room egoic
contraction
is our own conditioning and it is
so attaching we attach ourselves so
deeply to our psychology
to all of those layers of identity and
form which is why
inward even becomes difficult in the
first place because in order to
recognize your true nature as you
recognize your true nature
as rupert spyra says is that this little
moth
of the contracted egoic separate entity
it flies
into the white source light and
dissolves so you dissolve
your psychology you dissolve your form
you dissolve your identity
and people aren't willing to let go of
that
you know yet at the same time what
happens is as that dissolves
what happens is what emerges is god's
love light expressing itself as a pure
firework
into this creation that
a level that the psychological egoic
contraction could
never have healthfully expressed itself
yeah absolutely
yeah yeah and i think
i think there's a level of faith yeah
because it is it is kind of yeah to your
ego
it's quite threatening oh it's killed
it's just completely yeah it's
completely killed but one thing i think
um we've said this before that
it it does feel like you're shedding
those layers
which you can be attached to them and
you've identified with them for a while
so it can be hard to detach but
once you start recognizing those things
as not you
and you start letting them shut off of
you
what you're left with is just a just a
clear
sense of yourself like i was telling you
like by the end of this week i just i
feel more myself
just clearer yeah that's a great way to
play yeah absolutely
yeah the leaders have shed so many
cycles of death and rebirth like i've
said that many times i feel like i've
been through
lifetimes this week and just knowing
myself better being more clear
and knowing yeah that like we are so
connected and seeing myself and everyone
versus being so there you go
and you're i really like the metaphor of
the escape room
so do you feel like bentino and these
teachers give us
like would you say like the cheat codes
to that or would it be just like
it's probably it's probably yeah those
are good
ways to put it but probably the most
like perennial way that's been talked
about over thousands of years is this
just a pointing
point it's just pointing to the true
nature which is that
yeah you're already what you seek yeah
yeah yeah you're just sort of looking
around and you don't know
what to really land on like rumi says we
go from room to room looking for the
diamond that's already around our neck
and then we find that diamond that's
around our neck which is
really truly recognizing the poignancy
of
awareness itself and then as we do that
then we recognize that that is infinity
intelligent infinity endlessly
expressing and comprehending itself
yeah i love that and i've always
believed you know what you seek
is seeking you too there you go exactly
so like
it's always the guidance and then you
can try to run
from it you can try like many times i'm
like no i don't want to like
feel this and it's so but like once you
just surrender and like
it's so liberating right like instead of
trying to fight and swim as abraham
hicks says like i'm swimming upstream
i'm fighting the reality
no just like surrender and flow and just
know that you are going to be perfectly
placed
and perfect like you're going through
all of this every experience for
one for a reason and it's gonna lead you
back home every time
but we fight we try to swim upstream we
just try to resist and control
and all of that is just ego and knowing
that you can really surrender and
like allow your higher self you're the
one absolute whatever
you want to call it to lead your way
yeah
yeah right yeah i think we all have that
knowing that like that intuition lives
within us
but a lot of people i know are humans
they just resist it they're like i don't
want to feel it i don't want to think
about it so i'm going to like
numb it out drink it away smoke it away
whatever and like i think if these
things can be used intentionally but at
the same time
it's just if it's a numbing tool the
intention has to be there
and it's because it's just become very
clear to me that
floating downstream trusting and
surrendering to everything working out
with radiant ease
knowing that we are the power that gives
us that
this is that or is it that yeah yeah
yeah this
is that yeah yeah thank you and that
that for those that
yeah are interested in that that's a
really important
point from our entire retreat is that
the absolute is both what is
beyond even awareness what creates even
awareness and observes even awareness
observing its creations
yet the absolute is also
[Applause]
this
so this timeless presence
is that the highest
the absolute source
intelligent infinity this
is that yeah that's
really important that we brought that
yeah yeah
i wanted to go back to what you were
saying about um
like lack beliefs basically one thing
that was helpful that bentino talked
about was
looking at why you believe what you
believe
and it's always because there's some
benefit to you you perceive there's some
better
benefit to it like oh if i stress out
about
what's gonna happen next week i think
that i'm going to be able to solve it
better
or there's some reason that you're still
believing what you believe
so it's a really cool self inquiry
just to look at that yeah absolutely
and it is service itself right and like
it really just
makes us think that we are in control
and like oh i'm gonna fix this and do
this
and no like ultimately there's like some
strings up here
pulling us and making us like go we're
meant to go and like what is for
us cannot miss us and just knowing that
it's like
a relaxed your shoulders like you know
tongue away from the roof of the mouth
just a very
easy feeling just knowing that what is
for you can't miss you
but i think we get so yeah caught up in
like the control aspect thinking that we
really have control right like
could any of you like imagine that your
life would lead you right here
right and it's what did you say last
night was so good it's like we planned
this thousands of years ago in like a
movie
it was like it was so good yeah we we
14 billion years ago we wrote the script
we're watching the movie right now and
we're remembering what we wrote
i really adore that so much yeah
it's like a soul resonance you know and
yeah
what you're saying why do we do what we
do why do we think what we think and
like taking a step back
and thinking okay is that really serving
me anymore
likely no if it's these like habits
maybe
people places and things that fit our
comfort zone for so long but like if
they don't feel right anymore
or if they like restrict change and i
i think that's important to recognize
you know and yeah
change is our only constant we're going
to continuously change and if you have
people around you places around you that
restrict you from changing
then that's already kind of a little
[ __ ] move
yeah and you feel it like with the
emotional guidance system as you start
tuning into that more and then it gets
more and more
subtle and you'll feel that when you are
holding back or you're out of alignment
basically with
what those people places things thoughts
etc
states yeah that's really important yeah
so we created a general
creative exploration
designing the reality and then
as it unfolds you have these
analogies like we've been listening of
the escape room the stake in the rubber
band the emotional guidance system
alignment to the highest god's love
light
and so there is the will there is the
choice
all the time to recognize when
am i aligned versus when am i venturing
off into ego
separate entity seeking peace and
happiness from my uh
when are these happening and when are
they directing me back to the stake
yeah yeah that's it yeah yeah if you can
keep focusing on that that's
guides you home yeah guides your home
and you have to recognize when those
things don't feel good and i think
that's all perfectly placed in our
reality right it's not like to say that
you are making a wrong decision by
staying in these places
like with people that you know don't
really resonate anymore because the
contrast always serve its purpose right
like
you can't appreciate a delicious cup of
coffee if you've never had a shitty cup
of coffee you can't appreciate
a really resonant vibrational
relationship if you've never had
a relationship that feels so
constricting and just painful
ultimately that you can't be who you are
you can't appreciate unconditional love
you've never felt conditional love yeah
yeah so it all serves
it all serves this perfect contrast it's
perfection it is
this is perfect yeah it's just perfect
you know perfect we will end up where we
are meant to
always and it's never about the
destination because once you land there
you're going to have another journey to
go it's just about the journey
and realizing that it's all like
divinely timed and planned
dan elden said that the journey is the
destination
i love that and that over
thousands of years different
communities across the planet have been
making symbols that reflect the contrast
very commonly recognized as the yin and
yang
and that those two
poles in flux ascension
are ultimately in a monist
right so ultimately you have one
and the two in flux
upward and so we create the dark
to serve yeah
we've done some collective shadow work
this week damn we're all matching this
look
it actually looks like a really good
shot
that moment we had a moment last night
where we were just all laying beneath
the stars
and it was just a beautiful beautiful
completion moment to this whole week and
realizing that like
that yeah i think the right what did i
say the right people feel different to
your nervous system
and it's just all like divinely planned
realizing that everything is working out
best case scenario every moment
being open to the miracles of life
guiding you to exactly where you're
meant to be
and it feels so good it just feels
better it feels lighter
yeah guys you're releasing that
attachment
you know because it's like when you rest
in that perfection there's nothing that
you need
because you already realized that
what did you say it's a natural state
yeah i was saying that i feel so just
naturally high and it's unbelievable
i've never
like you know experienced that and it's
just a vibrational level that i've just
never felt that i've been at and you
said it's so simple
why do we make it so hard that's our
natural state
whoa yeah it's like crazy that we
think that we have to suffer our whole
lives and that's like the place that we
have to live in
oh life is just so hard and there's all
this lack
and i have to stay there forever because
i'm a human
and that's it you know and it's just
amazing when you can
awareness is everything like realizing
that you're not
at the yeah you're not like the less you
have the
choice to feel differently about every
situation yeah what is the quote like
looking at it as
what is this doing or like what is this
um
doing for me versus why is this
happening to me yeah like what is this
teaching me versus why is this happening
to me
that alone is a shift right there
perfect yeah
yep i love that and then when you get to
the highest levels you recognize
that i
created this teaching for myself
yeah it says it's right yeah it's such a
trip it's all about
perfect friends it's perfect and that's
why
also to play on what you were saying a
moment ago
is that sad guru has been really
influential in
communicating the statement of i
never do drugs but i'm always high
right and so how what does that mean why
do the mystics
talk about as the mysticism means
union with god with the absolute what
how to optimize said
self slash god slash infinity
realization
and also how to and
why does that then create this feeling
of timeless
perfection that radiates like the sun
with peace and joy
and just butterfly effects out right so
that's why
five years ago looking at these yogis
and mystics
just like what did they
do to feel like this all the time
and then just relentlessly relentlessly
relentlessly putting it in that north
star position of highest desire
surrendering all other things nothing
else besides
know thyself know thyself i want to know
my metaphysical truth or i'll die go
go go go go go go go and boom you pierce
the veil
the veilless veil and boom you recognize
yourself
as the creator that beautiful
i feel so good and
there's a quote i don't want to get too
tangent but on
spirituality is like the ocean and
religion is like a fishbowl within that
ocean
right and i really love that because
it's all pointing to the same thing
right we get so in these dogmatic uh
restrictions and like why do you even
think that is it just for control
is that what you think it is it was a
fundamental step
right absolutely so sri aurobindo and
the mother mural
also talk about how religion in a sense
prepares
the divine ascent it prepares
the individuated for the true
spirituality which yeah yeah and so
that's why we had these thousands of
years but also there was a lot of
perversion and there still is yeah yet
there's there's truth in especially the
mystic
traditions which are embedded within all
of these
you know billions of people around the
world are part of the religions but they
don't know that there's mystic
traditions in all of them that
talk about union with god with the
absolute
an actual inward process of uniting yeah
yeah yeah absolutely so it's there
what is the kingdom of heaven is within
yeah the kingdom of god is within
that's luke 17 21 yeah
and it is it all points within and
that's where
i just think it gets lost in translation
a lot when you're like feeling
constricted but
i think they all just point to the same
thing and that's where i feel like
spirituality mysticism has much more of
a broad spectrum of coming
home to that self within ourselves which
is
seeing you within me and every one
we're all on this journey and when you
separate
us when you separate us with religion
all of these others
identifying separations that like are i
feel like
made to control us and made to make us
feel individualized and puts that like
oh no you're not like me
all of this it's all for purpose to keep
you apart when in reality like
we are all one when we come together and
have that knowledge that like
what it is we're all walking each other
home
i love that quote it's one of my
favorite we're all walking each other so
perfect perfect perfect perfect yeah
i love it perfection perfecting
endlessly
endlessly endlessly
all walking each other home beautiful
beautiful
all right we love you thank you for
tuning in everyone
we're so grateful
i love you all
a sandwich yeah
[Music]
thanks everyone we'd love to hear from
you
in the comments below with your thoughts
on that episode let us know
also if the video brought you value give
it a like if you haven't yet subscribe
to the channel
also share the video with people that
you feel like it would make a positive
influence on
we have some links in the bio below
probably your
instagram profiles or like yeah we'll
put some links in the bio below if you
want to
follow hillary and gina and
[Music]
we adore you thank you so much thank you
thank you thank you that was so sweet
okay much love everyone yes
[Music]
is